thank you
[Music]
we gotta give a big congratulations to
Twitter Bay oh yeah
because
she is set to open her first restaurant
in the La Hacienda area in West
Hollywood upscale Vietnamese
I'm excited
so excited yeah it's great but there's a
little bit of a weird thing that I
thought we should stand up for her about
why because I don't like her though
try to try to stimulate that you like no
no like all of her recipes on Instagram
they look [__] bomb I can't wait I
wanna I wanna try it okay but you don't
like her as a person no no just a recipe
so hi thanks to net shark we now know
some really ridiculous opinions
basically they posted that like hey this
restaurant's opening up and if you know
where it's opening up you know that
that's a very nice area I think the
address that it's going to be open on is
where poppy currently is which is one of
those La Cienega that's baller yeah
that's like where all the celebrities
eat exactly is that we're like that's
like close to Beverly Center uh north of
it no yeah sort of yeah sort of but
there's like even more like higher than
Beverly Center type places closer to it
than that so
um in that restaurant area most places
you're expected to spend a lot of money
to eat there a lot of SBE kind of like
properties you know so it got out there
that the the cost per person would
average around 75.
75 bucks the most expensive Vietnamese
food yeah yeah but it's really nice it'd
probably yeah exactly yeah that's a good
thing right that that now we have an
upscale representation in that market
now that market has Vietnamese
representation within that Society so
she's trying to she's trying to elevate
exactly the whole like perception of
Vietnamese food that's dope man I wish
someone tried to elevate Chinese food oh
they got a lot of that right do they
it's all like five dollars for a whole
pile of [__] that's pouring out the
Starfall they got they got Chin Chin not
too far away from that Chin Chin
never heard of it
I never heard about Chinese finders dim
sum spots
yeah there's a lot of the the biggest
name of like higher quality like Chinese
yeah it'll be tied to like in China they
have it you know there's fine dining
Chinese food would be dope to have fine
dining that you could actually think
anything fine dining you should think
like Steakhouse or like chap or uh
French yeah Italian or whatever well you
know what happens is that because
Chinese food is so much already familiar
I think it just gets fused I think
you'll get a lot of fusions with like
Chinese food that's elevated by via
other cultural things and then they just
end up being everywhere like all the
nice restaurants in that area probably
have something Chinese I see yeah like
they're versions of it yeah yeah but
this is the first of its kind basically
it's dope and people are complaining of
course they are who what are they
complaining about because this is what I
don't understand right is like Haters
Gonna Hate yeah so why listen to what
these [__] morons have to say but at
the same time
I'm very curious like what why people
have a problem with people making a new
twist out of something like did they
expect way to have like a [__] five
dollar Pho restaurant which is unheard
of her uncle with three teeth is saying
I bring this from the Vietnam best spot
in the world you know it's like arguably
it could be worse because it would
compete with a no-name mom and pop [__]
shop that's also five bucks and it would
price them out she's also trying to be
different than what the market has
available right what she's doing what I
feel like is happening with this because
I live in this area and I'm like okay I
get it if she enters that market she's
competing with those other restaurants
she's not competing with other
Vietnamese restaurants she's bringing
Asian fusion into that world right put
it on the map yeah and she's making it
available to people who want to pay that
price and I think people have a
misunderstanding when it comes to fine
dining it's like when you have a Cuisine
that's looked at as cheap she's probably
using the highest quality premium
ingredients that cost a little a lot
more money than just like whatever they
use at your local the prep that you yeah
it's not it's not your average like
Vietnamese food I think people are
expecting it to be like a regular pho
place but it's like no people at neck
shark actually said that she's pricing
out Vietnamese people from eating their
own food it's not for them
all Vietnamese people are so broke they
can't afford 75 bucks for a plate like
you're you're pricing them out it's like
you're acting like there's no wealthy
Vietnamese the pricing you out here yeah
Johnny
20 bowls right now yeah for 500k this
guy's making changes he said opening up
a restaurant like this does not mean the
other Vietnamese restaurants are closing
it's not like now everyone has to pay 75
bucks you can't get yeah they're just
hating ass dumb asses dude that's like
okay when I let her live
bro yeah I'm an uncultured swine right
so I remember paying like over a hundred
bucks for some boom and I'm the whole
time I'm eating foam and I'm going like
[__] [__] I'm I want a
McDonald's yeah but that's because I'm
uncultured swine right I'm like why am I
doing this and then later someone
explains to me what fine dining all this
stuff is it's like when you're a peasant
[__] and you just want nutrients you
just want to fill up because you just
[__] want to eat but he goes you have
to think about the experience when
you're balling you're not hungry and
looking to you you want sustenance you
want an experience yeah you can eat
whatever the [__] you want so you're
you're also not stuffing yourself every
[__] day right you're eating more
like you're not
a Savage like me who likes to stuff till
I'm about to [__] puke give me the
buffet That's My Style yeah when I'm
there I'm you you go this is how you're
supposed to do it you're supposed to
look at it it's supposed to visually
make you go whoa this is pretty yeah
it's an artistic experience and then
you're like tasting it now their smell
senses everything and then even to the
to the decor and the atmosphere you're
in and like that whole experience that's
just you're it's just you're walking
into an art gallery and then you're
tasty yeah and I was like I didn't see
it that way I said I'm spending a
hundred bucks this does I'm getting this
much I leave hungry [__] this [__] and
I'm like this is why I'm uncultured
swine I don't get it no you're right
that's a really good point because the
way that this could be equated is like
you said Fine Art so what happens when
you put Fine Art in front of people that
don't appreciate art they go I could
paint that [__] yeah yeah so if you take
this food that's me the ingredients she
puts into it and you make it five bucks
and you give it to a person that that
wants to pay five bucks you have a
higher chance of them going is all right
yeah you know what I mean it's better
over there it's a whole experience
that's not that is not the situation
right this is this is finally going to
be a restaurant that can be open to
people that are used to eating at other
you know different Italian restaurants
French restaurants and then now they can
include Vietnamese in this area for
these like people that are more affluent
and more wanting to have that exact
experience you need but there's a
difference between casual dining upscale
dining fine dining and it's like just
that's what you're you're going to these
different experiences for a different
reason right so when you go to a place
where it's uh like because I'm sure she
puts so much thought into the menu and
all the different combinations of
flavors and textures and all that stuff
like some of these stuff that these
chefs do it takes a lot of [__] time
a lot of prep work and for it should
cost 75 a person because all the
experience yeah all the work that they
do just to get like one little potato
crisp have you seen like some of the
stuff on YouTube or Instagram like they
do crazy stuff where you're like what
the [__] is this machine and it's art it
is Art but you do have to like
understand what you're eating and what
you're consuming yeah but then for 75 I
go to Vegas buffet that's what I'm
saying I get crab legs I get oh
unlimited soft serve at the end are you
talking about Circus Circus because you
can't get out there
if you keep an open mind I think you
could actually like let more joy into
your heart that's definitely I actually
had an 80 bowl of ramen before at David
Chang's Restaurant how dare you I think
it's a the Momofuku or major Dome or
whatever but like his stuff I think it's
it's dope because you can see he took
Asian food which most of it is like
um like Family Soul Food right like it
reminds you of the recipes your mom made
or your grandma made or whatever he took
it and he elevated it like he had like
this smoked Branzino thing with some
like uh but then it was like Japanese
style where like he put like is it is
the uh flavoring agent in ramen called
tare or something
yeah it's like the broth yeah like so
people like smoked tari on [__]
Branzino he had an 80 bowl of ramen with
like Truffles and stuff and it was like
an experience like when you eat it
you're like oh [__] this is [__] Next
Level right so it's cool to see uh
people try to put effort in and like how
can I make Vietnamese food like next
level yeah yeah and I think all food
deserves that why can't sushi have that
large of a yeah a cost spread why can't
there be hundreds of dollars worth of
sushi and also Ralph's yeah you know I
mean like you're serving a different
Market why can't French food why can't
Italian food have Sbarro and also
something yeah yeah yeah
it starts from Sbarro if you think about
Vietnamese food already that already has
so many aspects of French like influence
right so then we and French like food is
like very it can be very elegant very
fine dining considered the top Cuisine
yeah exactly for a reason right so like
it's it's adjacent and she's probably
one of the first ones that's able to
take this take and and serve it to a
wide audience like why you can't knock
her for that if I if I give you this big
Vietnamese coffee at a place for fifty
dollars yeah and I'm not cracked up for
four days I'm gonna be pissed
[Laughter]
but yeah dude uh
Toyota Bay congratulations on your
restaurant
it's fun don't eat there if it's too
much
do you have any uh sample items on the
menu do you know oh yeah it's a secret I
it's nothing I understand because I'm
just a lowly Filipino that just eats egg
rolls
foreign